so israel
i've been trying to help you for quite a
while now and i just figured it's
probably time to do a little update on
what's been going on i uh
when i when we first started working
together
when i first started helping you i was
i told you the plan was to get you out
of the hood out of the neighborhood away
from the gangs
change your phone number
relocate
kind of cut all ties to that world
and build a new life for you and your
kids and
for a while it was going great it was it
was
it was going very smoothly you and i
were communicating really well i was
giving you yeah i got you a car i got
you a a monthly apartment and uh
i was giving you three four hundred
dollars a day
for you and your kids
and then
right around the time of the second
video
some things changed i noticed you uh
the communication change like
instead of having conversations or
whatever kind of communication we had
which was great it became just money
requests
just short little like i need 700
i need eight hundred dollars i need a
thousand dollars
it even grew to like there was a couple
days where i think i gave you a thousand
then you asked for a second thousand in
the same day two thousand dollars you're
up in the mountains with your you were
you you went to the mountains with your
boys yeah yeah and then uh
there were days where you needed two
thousand dollars and uh
i questioned you on that because it
seemed like a hell of a lot of money to
be giving you know a mom and two kids
but
i was out of town you were out of town
the cabins can get expensive i guess or
the ski lifts or whatever and
i just said let me just ride this out
and see how it goes
and then i came back from my trip
and i'm uh
i'm driving to uh the gym in the morning
5 30 in the morning it's dark and i
happen to drive past your apartment on
my way to the gym and i look at your
place and the lights are on
but you're out of town i'm like that's
weird you left the lights on no big deal
and then the next day i drive past and
the lights are off and the blinds are
open
and i'm like something's
something's going on
so
i was just confused
and with those large money requests
which were happening on a daily basis it
just got
it got to look very suspicious so i
asked you to get together and meet
rather than just texting
and uh
when you did come over
yeah i was waiting for you at your
apartment
you're a few hours late
and i had to use the bathroom at some
point i i went to your
i couldn't find anywhere to go to the
bathroom so i just figured i'm paying
for that apartment i should just use her
bathroom so i go to the manager
and ask for a second key
to your apartment and the manager goes
oh we already gave out the second key
and i'm like who would you give a second
key out to you're not going to give it
to your young kids
and i go that's strange that the second
key is missing oh there's a black guy
that goes that comes in and out of that
apartment all the time
and i'm like there is
and i
you know my suspicions kind of like
start you know all the pieces start to
fit so
i
took the key they gave me the master key
and i go up there and uh
i open up the door and i expect a lot of
kids stuff and toys and you know when
you have kids there's all kinds of
toys and shoes and clothes and stuff
like that
instead there's lots of
other stuff
there were adult sex toys and
outfits and a lot of other stuff like
that but
no signs of any kids in that apartment
and there's definitely a dude around
and so
tell me tell me what's what what things
turned into because it wasn't
i'd love to hear your your side of the
story because it
it isn't what i had planned
yeah i know um
so it's just a preface you have a very
serious gang background right
yes yeah the blood gang in south central
which i think is the is the um the no
the blood gang is the ex that originally
had the kids
but um
my ties are with the crib oh you're
crypts yeah oh i see okay yeah
so yeah
that's where he's from
and
so the money i was giving you the the
thousands and up that that was going to
him yeah
majority of it yeah
and this happens a lot just so for
people that are
unaware of this i've done this with a
lot of
girls in your situation and it
very often will go into this kind of
scenario where a dude will walk in and
come in and they're either trying to
extort money from me they're trying to
rob me they're trying to they're trying
to figure out some way to get the money
from you from me from whoever
and they become very greedy very quickly
so that was happening here
yeah
and this is this is a guy that you are
romantically involved with as well right
yeah
you uh
so tell me how you stand on all this
it's
i don't know it's kind of like um
i don't know it's like a lot to take in
like i feel like
like you know he's not
a bad person but not a good good person
i guess you could say to be around
and this this whole gang life has been
part of your life since you were 13 or
so right yeah
so when you when you finally did show up
that
that day that afternoon
at your apartment i kind of called you
out on all this stuff and you basically
just denied it and
said no no no there's been no guy around
here for a long time and i'm like
so i think it's this is not your
behavior that we're seeing i think
you're being
you're being controlled probably
is that what i mean i hate to put words
in your mouth but
i don't think you're going to even say
it
because you're afraid of
repercussions from saying anything right
because you'll see this video and all
that so i don't want to get you in
trouble but but typically that's how it
goes down
with these gang member type dudes
they're they're hustling girls
because they're gang member pimps and
that's what this is probably looking
more like
it's a very different thing and very
dangerous and for me
i'm too busy and too involved in all
these other things to even get involved
in any of this gang stuff
and i just don't have time for for this
kind of shenanigans and
and all that kind of
bs so
so i i've told you that i'm out i can't
you know these people are these viewers
of mine are donating money to a gofundme
and a lot of that money goes to you
but it looks like that money is now
starting to go to somebody else and i i
got to protect that
so that's why i told you i'm done with
your my help
which is a shame because you have so
much potential and so many people
believe in you and want to help you
but you're under the control of somebody
who who's very dangerous and
and i can you know he
your behavior it seems more loyal to him
than to me
you know i'm just trying to help you and
your your kids out but
in doing that i end up helping him out
which is not my intention
so
is there anything that you'd like to say
about any of this
i mean not really
i don't know if it's time for law
enforcement to come in and do something
i i
i can't do this as one guy with a camera
i'm just i'm just a dude
that
found this little story that's
interesting but i can't start fighting
the crips by myself with a camera yeah i
can only do so much
and i got to protect my own
safety and
stuff like that i feel for you and i'd
love to help you but i tried i tried to
relocate you
i want you to change your number and
that never happened and i
i thought i had a good plan in place but
next i know the dude's living in your
apartment with you
so i don't know where i can go from here
i don't know what i can do i can't i
can't help much further while there's
people like this involved in this
situation
so what what's his his name is
your your dude's name uh fly fly
and he's outside
yeah you wanna see if i can get him to
come in
yeah well he parked around the corner
because it was like no parking let me
see if i can get them come in
all right so
this is fly
and
you are
how would you describe yourself you are
is various boyfriend
yes
are you are you her
money manager as well yes
would you call it a pimp
i wouldn't use that per se but yeah
yeah yeah you guys have known each other
for a while yeah
and you're
[ __ ]
yes i am your [ __ ]
you grew up in south central yes
so
yeah i was trying to help out as ryan
with uh
you know getting a stable situation for
her and her kids and help her with the
drug addiction and education and job and
you know supporting herself
right and the money i was giving her
started increasing and increasing
increasing i was giving out thousands a
day at some point
i think that was probably going to you
at some point
yeah yeah
and that's because you're her money
manager right does that does that money
where's that money go because she's
still asking me for like 25 for gas and
stuff like that so she's not getting it
and go towards me the kids
and sometimes her depends on what it is
and you've been doing this
kind of work for how long
since i was 18.
how do you know 30 30.
you've been prison time
yes i have
what kind of stuff for
just minor possessions
you know
it's nothing too much yeah
yeah i'm sorry you guys just had a
miscarriage recently i'm sorry about
that yeah
um you uh where do you
are you trying to help us ryan anyway
yeah she helped me i'm trying to help
her get out this life
once you win it you win it it's hard to
shake it but i'm trying
yeah it's a hard it's it's hard getting
out of the
the hood
you guys grew up you guys both of you
grew up a lot of people i interviewed
grew up in these
in a household that was just everyone
was hustling everyone's just trying to
survive right yeah my whole family game
members
your whole game family is gang members
yeah
no and once you come from that
environment
you can't just go to
chipotle and get a job and
survive you're going to have to figure
out some hustle that's all you've ever
known right the role models you had were
probably
drug dealers and pimps
yeah
so you can't i can't really blame you
for anything yeah i i could point the
finger at azraya for you know lying to
me but then
then it goes to you but then it's not
even you it's your
family or parents or role models or
grandparents or or
i don't even know it gets very confusing
because you can you can you can blame
poverty or you can blame uh lack of
education lack of opportunities that you
guys had you could blame the rich for
not being
not sharing their wealth
and it gets it gets very messy
it really do very complicated
but
i wish you guys the best of luck
and i hope you uh you guys figure figure
out a way to
get a better life for her and her kids
and and for yourself and uh
i hope you guys have a great a great
year
me too all right man thanks sir thanks
ryan
you